Chris Hemsworth is back as Tyler rake in
extraction too which probably seems like
a no-brainer unless you're a fan of the
first movie then it's a little confusing
here's how the character made his
seemingly unlikely return the following
is technically a spoiler for the Netflix
action film extraction so consider this
your warning
at the end of the movie rake's fate is
in question after he completes the
rescue mission referenced in the title
this plot point is openly incorporated
into the promotion for its sequel of
course once the streaming service
announced that Hemsworth would return an
extraction too thus endings ambiguity
was nullified and Tyler's survival
became canon in fact the first teaser
Netflix shared for extraction 2 in
September of 2021 opens on footage of
the ending of the first extraction
before closing with some brief new
footage of Tyler opening his eyes
underwater in the wake of his seemingly
fatal injuries Netflix and encourages
viewers to share the hashtag rake lives
the second teaser for the sequel
elaborates on how Tyler survived without
quite clarifying how exactly he was
saved from his predicament a mysterious
voice explains as we see Tyler receiving
medical treatment you are clinically
dead nine months ago would you fought
your way back with that in mind a couple
of details about the film's production
provides some additional insight into
just how Tyler is capable of return
running for the upcoming extraction
sequel extraction is based on a comic
title to see you Dad by author Andy
Parks and as it turns out the comic
sending is less ambiguous than the films
but extraction also see you died in
certain key ways the most notable of
which is the fact that weather films
Tyler rake is escorting a boy named OVI
in the original story Tyler is
responsible for a girl named Eva the
climactic extraction scene in which
Tyler's pursuers shoots him when he
falls into a river is adapted from the
comic but while that moment maybe the
last viewer sea of Tyler in the film The
Comic continues and reveals that Tyler
arrives intact at a hospital in
Argentina viewers then can simply
presume that's in the extraction film
series just as in see you Dad Tyler
survives both as bullet wounds and the
possibility of drowning long enough to
ensure his rescue part of why the first
movie ended on such a question mark is
that Tyler rake wasn't always supposed
to survive extraction director Sam
Hargrave revealed in an interview with
collider that Tyler's death was explicit
in the film's original script Netflix
even produced a version of the film in
which Tyler's death is Canon but it's a
mixed reception among test audiences let
the extraction team to decide upon the
more ambiguous conclusion Hargrave added
that when he started work on extraction
he believed Tyler's death to be a worthy
sacrifice for obi's sake however after a
conversation with Netflix executive
Scott stupor about intellectually
satisfying versus emotionally satisfying
endings Hargrave came to the conclusion
that viewers might feel more emotionally
satisfied knowing that Tyler's
attachment OV helped him defy death and
keep living because some viewers might
find the story of extraction more
satisfying if Tyler survives and others
if he dies hargraven companies settled
on an ambiguous ending that provides
enough evidence for either conclusion
extraction 2 then at least with
Hemsworth in the lead again was only
possible because its predecessor's
original ending was changed and allowed
for the possibility of Tyler's survival
[Music]
of course extraction 2 will likely
reveal more details about the nature of
Tyler's return when it premieres on
Netflix June 16th 2023